I didn't bring you here just to sip some
tea I wanted to spill some tea so I
thought of a game I like to call it sip
it and spill and it's basically a very
sophisticated version of never have I
ever
so I'll start because there's something
I'm actually very interested in and I've
never seen a ghost and I want to see it
go so I'm very mad that I have it have
you ever been scared but a high clear
castle ghost okay you're sipping I
haven't been scared by it but put it
this way when shirley maclaine was on
the show she of course has probably
lived at their castle she said he said
she's been in this room before as we
said they're having dinner so I think
that's a one step removed from being in
touch oh my gosh she was there the day
before we were filming that wasn't you
this is why I love her she's slightly
nutty we have the same birthday I'm
slightly nutty so yeah I thought
Tauruses are all weird but yes but we're
fun right um all right so anybody you
want to go now maybe Elizabeth you want
to go sip it and spill it if you have a
DJ alter-ego at this table a DJ
alter-ego
what what what tell us more I'm always
that person at a party I get all the
tunes going and everything and my
Spotify playlist is called DJ Dockers
however that has recently been blown out
important and apparently I'm spinning
the Dex and I be throw me it's not true
okay Michele go ahead sip it and spill
it if you're related to Indiana Jones
Harrison Ford what my grandfather was an
explorer and he was the first white man
to go into Tibet and he wrote a book
about it and then he did a whole bunch
of exploring in his life and somebody on
Google made up that he was the
inspiration for Indiana Jones yeah
that's way cooler than the Harrison Ford
thing I thought I was like oh okay okay
I still like yours all right
sip and spill it if you've ever ridden a
bicycle on a motorway I decided to shake
it up a little and instead of taking the
car to the dance rehearsal I would ride
my bike to the dance rehearsal and
everything was going well and I had my
helmet on it was going and I went up
this little slip road and I was oh my
god I was on freeway I taken a wrong
turn and you were going the opposite way
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
let's talk about the movie though
everybody's so excited about it this
really deserves to be seen on a big
screen because because it's so much more
sort of lush and vibrant and epic than
we had even on the TV show which in
itself is quite cinematic and I think
that's that's the major difference I
think fans who followed the show from
the beginning will be delighted that
it's a continuation of the story and
even for people who don't know the
characters in the series it's a it's a
standalone story and it was really the
support of the fans that drove it they
got us all back together because I think
if that appetite hadn't been there from
the fans and then we wouldn't be sitting
here now you're lovely tea table around
sip it and spill it if you've had the
greatest time ever at the move
[Applause]
well you do in America subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going